the first ever test match took place
here in 1880 but it also allows us to
look to the future as well having
delivered 100 tests is is great but now
we're looking to understand um what the
future looks like and for us we believe
test match cricket is it has a very
bright future we sell out many of our
games
and so it's an opportunity to look to
the future also
sorry he's been through a rough patch in
recent years in 2010 you had to lay off
an awful lot of people you weren't there
of course at that time but how have you
turned things around since we we've
tried to reduce our alliance on
international cricket
and we've done that through domestic
cricket so the 2020 has been a great
success for us
we've just uh hosted three sellout games
in an eight day period and generated
additional revenue from that which is
excellent also just trying to make sure
that we use this great venue on
non-match days and we now routinely host
about 1500 non-cricket matched at
non-cricket events
every year and that's bringing in extra
revenue for us you've obviously had a
great time here with 2020 recently could
the club financially stand on its own
two feet without that um without t20 it
would be a struggle because as your
expenditure
our expenditure normally matches our
income we're not for profit organization
so as we generate more money we're
seeking to invest it back into the
either the the facilities or into
developing players so we're always
trying to make sure that our income and
our expenditure are matched where we're
not a profit making organization we're
here to deliver successful qriket teams
great players and an outstanding venue
obviously surrey was one of the counties
that opposed the new cities 2020
competition do you worry about the
impact that's going to have on the
business
we don't know at the moment the new 2020
competition doesn't start for another
three seasons
um
in the end we did come on side with the
ecb because we could understand the
direction of travel of course we were in
a fairly unique position
um
because we sell out all of our 2020s
that's not the case across the entire
country although many more counties are
doing much better now and so you could
see from the ecb's perspective perhaps
that they wanted to have a 2020
competition which was universally
successful
obviously there's a lot of debate about
allocation of test matches are you
pretty confident that the oval will
continue to host test cricket for the
foreseeable future i i would hope so
that's up to the ecb um
when the allocation process uh begins
but uh having just celebrated at 100th
test there's only now four venues in the
world that delivered that
and uh with our track record of selling
out matches and providing a great
spectacle it would seem at least to us
to be a strange decision were the amount
of international cricket to be reduced
so
but we're not taking anything for
granted we're always looking to reinvest
in our facilities and make sure that we
provide the customers with the very best
experience now you've got plans to
redevelop the ground increase the
capacity here to 40 000. what's going to
be the next step in that
yes we're going to do that in
three or four tranches i'm just doing
some more work on that
the the initial element is probably
going to be the lock lakers stand which
is an old victorian stand which we'll
look to take down and replace that with
that with uh with a two-tier stand an
increased capacity um we're currently at
25 and a half thousand we sell out
county cricket we sell out international
cricket when the new 2020 competition
comes along we hope that
we can sell that out also and so we need
to keep up with demand and can that
redevelopment be funded from existing
finances
well the existing business plan uh uh
will survive for the next four or five
years because that's the um that's the
amount of uh that's the view and the
that we have in terms of the allocation
of international cricket beyond that yes
of course we need to make sure that we
remain an international venue
if we are not hosting international
cricket it will be impossible to create
a business plan to increase the capacity
to meet demand